[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in or what would I
do without you you'll always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa
there's just voice voice what does that
mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming that's normal
where are we
how did you get in the force the mist
parted for as impossible where did you
learn magic
[Music]
you can't just follow me into fire then
don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa
anyone or anything
quick question is the whole putting up
some Mortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
you